But the Beatles, they weren't the first rock stars.
They'd be the first to say that others had opened that door for them.
But they blew the walls down for everybody else.
In a few short years, they had changed the way that we listened to music,...
...thought about music and performed the music forever.
They helped to lay the soundtrack for an entire generation,...
...an era of endless possibility and of great change.
And over the four decades since,...
...Paul McCartney has not let up,...
...touring the world with the band "Wings" or on his own,...
...rocking everything from small halls to Super Bowls.
He's composed hundreds of songs over the years with John Lennon,...
...with others or on his own.
Nearly 200 of those songs made the charts, think about that...
...and stayed on the charts for a cumulative total of 32 years.
And his gifts have touched billions of lives.
As he later confessed at the Beatles' first appearance on The Ed Sullivan Show,...
...where he carried that bass out,...
...that one evening that changed everything,...
...Paul said, "Luckily, we didn't know what America was."
"We just knew our dream of it, or we probably would have been too intimidated."
Tonight, it is my distinct pleasure...
...to present America's highest award for popular music on behalf of a grateful nation,...
...grateful that a young Englishman shared his dreams with us,...
...Sir Paul McCartney.